coming home I think the best part was
seeing my family and friends in feeling
this immense love and pride and this
feeling great to see them and then just
walking on terra firma again you know
not floating around but just feeling the
earth beneath you it's a beautiful
moment
I had those moments of where am I in my
space and my at home I'm on the ground
how I'm gonna move I'm gonna eat a
mother throw food an affair and go fine
get it to walk on the beach was just the
most incredible thing when you look at
the horizon it kind of helps regain your
gyros in your inner ears it helps you
know exactly what's up and down and
right and left
driving felt interesting because you had
been traveling at 17,500 and then you
come back and you get in your car you're
like 160 miles an hour huh what stuff
100 miles on us RS nothing it changes
the way you think about speed I think
food tasted better after eating the
rehydrated vegetables in the irradiated
turkey coming home to a wonderful meal
and sharing it and not having to go
chase it when it bounces off or
something and you can you know pick it
up you know it's coming to your mouth
you know that's that's pretty cool if
you want to go to space it would be one
of these things that is transformative
on so many different levels
I would tell future explorers to make
sure that when you work with others that
you work as a team you see all people as
potential you know space travelers
together no matter what language they
speak no matter what they look like they
might what food they eat and to know
that we're all in this together and work
hard and share the fun